[Musik]
so mit der Krim
Sirup kam mit 19 nach Kiew
Ich bin jetzt 34 Jahre alt, meine Eltern kamen
sofort außer
Sami kam mit Papa Crimean nach Russland
Tatar und würde sagen, dass Sie werden
dort aus Russland
Bohrung kennen Träger verstecken ihre
Gefühle und das ist eine Straße
rauche nicht Mama es scheint mir so
kluges Mädchen
aber
[Musik]
wollen sich verstecken
für 6k werden einige Zeit sehr
was wir können Dreifaltigkeit
[Musik]
Also Freunde des 21. Jahrhunderts
Keller der Stadt Cherson
die meisten hier haben das Ganze bereits geboren
kleine Kinder und hier haben wir 2
auf dem Weg
sag hallo bitte
[Musik]
sehr 10 cm
Essen
[Musik]
Alles, was ich sagen möchte, ist diese xii-Beziehung
Sehr effizient ist diese Generation
was schon wächst, wird mit Hass sein
5 zu diesem Land, das ist genau eine Tatsache
im Allgemeinen ja, die Hölle weiß, wie ich es will
dass Russland sich als letztes weigert
Krankheit oder die Turmhälfte befallen
Weg
das Außenministerium der Ukraine das sind unsere Länder
[Musik]